okay yeah well I'm gonna come back a lot
of people have been like that's a psycho
babble like where have you been like
like I keep getting messages that say
like psychobabble like I can't sleep at
night like where are you and I'm here I
was just like digging in the backyard
okay it's create a profile okay and they
yeah okay Kay right congratulations he
was selected for the old world test face
okay thank you
now here's a profile picture uh no he's
gross hey stay dirty yeah he's too clean
um okay stay this guy I like I like it
the way he looks he just like I'm here
and just this is just a job and this is
one this guy's name is Anthony Hopkins
okay let's do this you may now enter
your email address
Oh what is this real oh it's optional
I'm aware that my actions may severely
impact the lives of citizens of the
nation yes okay I look there I lay in
judge objectively in the bathroom I
would sure thing while working on one
here two laws in jurisdiction of the
nation yeah sure
yes ma'am i Fred paycheck that's fine
with me thank you thank you
now where's Nicole they lock him in okay
oh wow
it's beautiful
I was that guy running and everyone
looks very calm and nice that's good
is that who is that never I could found
not good not good
I need to know everything now just power
ok Bebe's and if you want more power you
gotta make that it's ok let's sit here
ok there's a piece oh my god oh my god
what wait out together
that disgusts me that she just like
using public transport where the record
nothing makes me sicker than something
like that
Thank You Jay gotta go ok alright those
people are they kissing
God I got
they say what happens when you you kiss
before being married
do you see the dangerous okay let's go
ladies right at Mossad one that clocks
were striking there ten yeah I got it
sister
yeah line I got hey simps similar size
got my stamps be advisor I know well
together we formed the both the first
and last line of defense against
terrorism for its history were the first
people tried the overall system to real
circumstances selected five thousand
applicants across the globe no problem
there's been incidents like it started
there Rainer toll it purposes storing
bookmarks the online website talk of
easy access
first up I want you to be informed
situation our leading newspaper will
bring up the speed if it browser we hold
their vacuum profile open the unknown
person once you're done okay University
Villanova it's a freedom of morale
because three exposed to destroys the
afraid of oil on Banton through kill
five people secure injured strange
letter negotiations riots oh thank god a
hundred gray shadows around that is dang
right I was like a couple days ago and I
hope I shoot anyone
weird more no no what's a strange letter
Manuel eyes are so much for reading in
this sound fifteen I can't through
people were kill the app of course
exploited acts of terror yes of course
homemade they take used a cell phone
signal shirt away anonymous letter comes
first three stances of the German folk
song the thoughts are free
okay back to this map anything let's see
what there were Elko historias but or
feel like most my job just like reading
celebrity gossip and I calipari hmm Wow
okay a known person dad Abarth nobody
not but it's a main suspect the blue
haired woman's for the Sonos Trinity
please take a look at that our arrest
record I think it how do I look at her
and I do that
all right
there we go now I gotta get a reader huh
[Music]
[Music]
yeah are we sure this is her though
[Music]
we're so excited I've been struck by an
unknown object we don't responsive okay
and okay
okay what am I supposed to be doing drag
and drop all data chunks now the name
[Music]
okay there we go fine tater really worse
she attack peace officer and you'll see
what I mean honey
so so July 10th 2016
freedom class oh my god okay we got to
watch our mark and hello me
hello you watch our more well I feel
like half this game I don't know what
I'm doing
yeah okay listener I'll find more about
her there we go
what else don't we know better she's an
artist perfect and Kenny's gone - gone
he's blind
[Music]
okay sounds good to me
colorful inhabitant in Wonderland what
[Music]
this is what we gotta update this is the
important stuff wow this is so cool
actually
okay communications nothing as opposed
to just like wait
[Music]
in a relationship okay am I supposed to
just like you know I suppose describe
everything nothing's happening
[Music]
[Music]
okay oh oh here we go
heyyo heyyo say hey Joe say they the
boyfriend chase so done Cassandra you're
done you're done well this is so crazy
[Music]
[Music]
perfect
Oh direct recipe as Eric in a
relationship
[Music]
okay all right okay mr. Langley
[Music]
method in blue one thing is this
this is Jack methane blow again
[Music]
[Music]
wait oh crap okay
sorry this is a train wreck
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
I think
yeah where you go okay
she's the mother though crime rate
dropping
to safety but the safety bill
this is Jack anything hearing up chops
[Music]
[Music]
that's trash I didn't just like live
just timeline yeah someone did I am
painting the targets that's a bad way
right now way got you
[Music]
[Music]
let's say this by the case that's better
the case
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there we go this is good
[Music]
[Music]
yeah alright there's so many people here
how's it Brian ow
anything another one I said here's the
boyfriend
I know you got the head stare at that
place my son okay okay interesting she's
part of a group whether thought
she looks says that smashes she's done
Wow
oh no is he like
it's guessin it's that one
[Music]
well this price has gone insane I
already know what my thoroughness
signais that ever isn't can I just like
check on eyeliner I don't think I like
dead it though
[Music]
at Facebook
they're like okay overview what is this
now
entry one
and I can't do anything
[Music]
she did this
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
Oh
this is the person called fails
you know is this guy
they separate
okay
[Music]
let your herons in I'll let that go
I take like 10 years any projects post
on timeline what what all right
timeline let me check
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
let me say hey they interesting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
Shh down we gotta get her chaste I got
that job in just a place officer chased
on half huntsacker
she's done
[Music]
[Music]
okay we got her in custody second hey
close it Shay's us I already know it did
this to another paper let's see
[Music]
okay like dude like
misguided god fast
why is it keep on like sandwich stuff
here and not stuff here people
yeah
cheering our the nation possessions okay
I guess that's that
oh wait now there's got me more right
come fast can I get to this guy yeah I
guess that's it no I can't wait a pretty
good that I didn't way that's day one
right
I don't sigh next one thank you